now I want to go on to the next thing
related to Rudy Giuliani because I now
have video for you so bizarre and so
confusing that it's almost beyond belief
except it's the 2018 Trump
administration and everything is
believable so the first thing I talked
about on the program today was Rudy
Giuliani Trump's actual lawyer moving
from there was no collusion to collusion
wouldn't be a crime even if it happened
during some of these same interviews he
also started talking about a second
meeting related to the Russia Trump
Tower meeting ok I'm gonna try to set
this up in the clear as possible way
because it does start to get complex I
think by design he was interviewed on
CNN by Allison cammarata during that
interview Rudy Giuliani admits to a
previously unknown pre-meeting to the
Trump Tower meeting with the Russians
promising dirt on Hillary and it's like
we need a flowchart Pat to explain the
timeline of this thing the Trump Tower
Russia meeting was on July I'm sorry
June 9th of 2016 June 7 of 2016 as I
played for you yesterday Donald Trump
came out and said very very soon I'm
gonna have a bunch of dirt on Hillary in
this clip what Rudy Giuliani admits to
if you listen carefully amidst all the
confusion that he seems to be
experiencing himself is that that same
day June 7 2016 there was a meeting held
to discuss the upcoming meeting with
Natalia vessel Metz kaya and the entire
entire thing that we now know about
listen carefully to rule II remember to
Rudy we didn't know about this meeting
until Rudy mentioned it yesterday on CNN
the meeting with the Russians that how
can you be sure that the president
didn't know beforehand you're saying
it's just a he said hey I got nobody can
be sure of anything situation like this
you have two things that argue against
Cole chew on one I'm sorry three things
then you get to the other meeting he
says he was sad that the president
wasn't at it's three or four on one
that's the it also was added occult or
Lanny Davis has added that there was a
meeting two days before the meeting two
place with Donald Jr Jared Manafort and
two others gates and one more person and
that's a real meeting you're saying that
that that's a real meeting on Iran
another provable subject in which he
would not participate the meeting just
so I've been clear the meeting with the
Russians who was in there I have to
Jared yeah it was with Donald Jr yeah
Jared and to the three other people I'm
not sure of exactly who and but the one
who came in or Russia allegedly told the
president about it was Donald which
Donal denies the president denies and
there's no corroboration of and Cohen
has never said this at any time up until
now okay so Allison Cammarata says so
that was a real meeting and Rudy
Giuliani says yeah yeah that meeting
took place he denies that it was about
the Trump Tower meeting but of course
just hours later Donald Trump goes out
and says hey in a few days I'm gonna
have really big big stuff on Hillary
so of course Giuliani admits to this
other meeting having taken place
immediately it's huge people pick up on
it there was another meeting there was
another meeting apparently to talk about
allegedly to talk about the upcoming
Trump Tower meeting as you know that
same day Trump promises dirt on Hillary
so the timing of it is obvious but right
after this we hear the following from
Donald Trump just as a reminder from
yesterday that the timing it makes
perfect sense that there had just been a
meeting and Trump was coming from it and
then he says this Monday of next week
and we're going to be discussing all of
the things that have taken place with
the Clintons I think you're gonna find
it very informative and very very
[Applause]
the alleged meeting that Rudy Guiliani
confirmed on CNN took place just hours
before Donald Trump came out and said
that so then of course this gets really
bad for Trump and Rudy Giuliani so
immediately Rudy Giuliani calls back in
to Fox News remember he had already been
on Fox and Friends in the morning he
calls back into Fox News and then he
denies anything about the second the
second meeting now there was no second
meeting it's almost impossible to
understand Giuliani in this clip but
what he is clearly doing is denying now
that the second meeting happened which
he just previously confirmed happened on
CNN earlier the same day there wasn't
another meeting that has been leaked but
hasn't been in public yet ok that was a
meeting an alleged meeting three days
before
according to calling according to the
leak maybe cold over the druthers I
don't know they haven't pursued it and
the two publications they're not going
to publish it I think they found
independent contradiction he says there
was a meeting with Donald the junior
with Jared Kushner with Paul Manafort
with gates possibly two others in which
they out of the presence of the
president discussed the meeting with the
Russian we checked with their lawyers
the ones we could check with which was
four of the six that meeting never ever
took place
didn't happen so now he says it didn't
happen after saying just hours before in
CNN that it did everybody following so
far so then it was so confusing that
there was a follow-up question asked and
Rudy Giuliani making even less sense
well I let me just ask it this way so
you've never told us about two meetings
there was one that the public knows
about which when you talk about a
meeting and you say that the president
wasn't there that's the one that
everybody would assume that we're all on
the same page about but what you're
saying now is that there was another
meeting
that was leaked that has not been made
public and I would assume until now
really described by you Rudy Giuliani
and detail that happened three days
prior that had Don jr. Jared Kushner
Paul mana four gates and possibly two
others and that's the meeting that
Michael Cohen says the president was not
or the president knew about a
at a time but you say the promote was
not there no Cohen is not alleging I
don't look I don't know oh I have a to
report is telling me Cohen told them
there was a meeting three days before
with the group of people that I said and
that they discussed the committee and
that the president was not there he
didn't say the president knew about it
okay I am Telling You meeting didn't
take place never happened yes there was
another meeting which didn't take place
it's a meeting that doesn't exist so so
it's some sort of a meeting it's a meet
it's a non existent meeting and then
lastly here's a key thing rudy giuliani
choosing very careful language Giuliani
saying Trump was not quote at the
meeting which is important and I'll
explain after this is Melissa Francis
and I just want to jump in I don't think
any of that really addresses the
question of why you would say he wasn't
at the meeting no why are you saying
that the president wasn't at the meeting
I understand those two meetings that you
just said out there but that doesn't
explain why you're saying he was
American last if he was there no one has
to be was there Cohen is alleging the
meeting took place we are making it
clear that the president was not at that
meeting Cohen doesn't even allege that
to cut it off so Trump has a history of
listening to meetings via speakerphone
so they keep talking about how Trump
wasn't physically there he didn't have a
presence at the meeting he wasn't at
that meeting that to me is another one
of these signals that of course from
knew about it but he may even have been
connected via speakerphone but he wasn't
physically there I still am unsure this
is a strategy Pat right Giuliani could
be this dumb and this terrible of a
lawyer it could also be a way of
accidentally leaking things just to
cause confusion and to make it even more
difficult to know what the hell is going
on I really think he's this dumb though
and you know the Trump's best lawyers
are all now gone like Ty Cobb and John
Dowd and even Michael Cohen do you think
this is really as what you've left with
the B team yeah Rudy Giuliani's the guy
who was loyal to him and he rewarded
them with the job if this isn't some
brilliant strategy who needs prosecutors
when you've got Rudy Giuliani as your
defense attorney that's all the
prosecuting that that you really need
send me your thoughts what do you think
is going on here with this
informational shell game I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman and the show is on Twitter
at David Pakman show
today's program is sponsored in part by
Blink accom slash Pakman if you've not
already heard about blinka it's amazing
it's an app for your phone tablet or web
browser and what they do is they take
nonfiction books popular nonfiction
critically acclaimed nonfiction they
condense the book into a 15 minute audio
book you get all the most important
information and insights from each book
but you can soak up the entire essence
of the book in one sitting I've listened
to a ton of books on blinkin recent one
is a robert righteous new book the
common good also bunk by Kevin Young
useful in preparing me for the
pseudo-science miniseries that we're
producing and if you are a david pakman
show viewer or listener you can get a
seven day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
youtube use the link in the video
description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n